bienvenue dans PAF déjà de numéro 5 pas
vous savez ce sont des débats sur des
sujets d'actualité avec une bande et
aujourd'hui avec une nouvelle venue
Sephora Namani bonjour Patrice comment
ça va ça va bien très d'être parmi vous
on est très heureux de vous accueillir
vous êtes étudiante
faites vous êtes en master en Master 2
métiers de la culture à l'administration
culturelle publique et privée
dans les villes nouvelles enfin avec les
industrialisations à remplacer un peu
l'industrie maintenant on fait plus de
la culture
on fait plus d'industries enfin c'est
comme ça enfin bonne chance et merci
d'être avec nous en tout cas à côté de
vous je vous présente Mustapha oui vous
connaissez évidemment puisque c'est le
président du Football Club de trappes et
qui est aussi pharmacien à ses heures
perdues comment ça va ça va bien merci
merci bonne semaine
on a beaucoup de clients fidèles c'est
bon signe pour un restaurateur
alors un mot quand même sur le
Groupement National des indépendants
dont vous allez devenir le trésorier
national absolument donc c'est un énorme
groupe de d'ateliers de restaurateurs de
cafetiers de brasseurs de traiteur de
discothèque qui se rassemblent puisqu'en
fait les syndicats étaient un peu
éparpillés ce qui est là un fléau
français et là enfin tout le monde se
regroupe au sein de ce groupement
national et ça va faire du bruit c'est
plus de 20 000 entreprises que des
indépendants avec des personnalités
fortes évidemment c'est toujours comme
ça chez les petits patrons et tant mieux
c'est une bonne chose mais ils ont
besoin maintenant d'être entendus d'une
seule voix et pour ceux qui me concerne
je travaille dans le syndicalisme depuis
une bonne trentaine d'années donc c'est
pas un million inconnu pour moi là
maintenant je prends les reines de la
trésorerie de ce groupement
je pense que nous allons avoir aussi des
choses à dire dans un métier qui
aujourd'hui est en révolution
à la fois chez les hôteliers et chez les
restaurateurs faites attention parce que
les trésorier c'est eux qui prennent
on va faire propre c'est essentiellement
des métiers de bouche essentiellement
des métiers de bouche mais comme nous
n'avons pas voulu associer au groupement
national des indépendants le mot
hôtelière restaurateur c'est ouvert je
dirais à l'ensemble des organisations
professionnelles qui représentent les
petites entreprises TPE PME dans des
activités divers et variées pour
l'instant nous sommes très axés hôtel
restauration mais nous accueillerons
avec grand plaisir toutes les autres
organisations artisanales pour la
plupart et pas seulement dans les
métiers de bouche d'ailleurs est-ce que
vous prenez des éditeurs par exemple et
bien oui parce que je sais que
Jean-Charles est un été un éditeur
indépendant
difficultés de l'indépendance à son
grand groupe Jean-Charles et les
éditions
de remonter une maison d'édition il y a
tout le monde trouve c'est un peu un peu
gonflé mais en fait en tout cas c'est
passionnant c'est vrai que c'est un peu
compliqué par moments au point de vue
financier parce que c'est un métier
difficile économiquement mais un petit
peu comme tout en ce moment enfin tu
parlais de révolution c'est vrai que
c'est aussi une révolution c'est entre
les librairies qui ferment les grosses
librairies qui s'ouvrent est-ce que le
livre va survivre voilà moi je suis très
optimiste en tout cas le lit va sûrement
survivre et on parlera d'un des livres
que vous publiez tout à l'heure
puisqu'on parlera des commémorations de
la guerre de 14 et vous obtenez un très
très joli livre de notamment
tout à l'heure
Sephora est-ce que vous avez vu le tigre
l'université non il est temps il est
tout en Seine-et-Marne tu vois oui alors
je sais pas si je dirige va voir mieux
non je ne l'ai pas encore vu mais il
paraît qu'il ne serait dangereux que
s'il a très faim donc j'espère pour le
moment
15 heures par jour ou entre 15 et 20
heures par jour et ça ça peut manger une
fois tous les 10 jours donc si la manger
avant de partir
on est totalement tranquille à mon avis
dans un biotope à peu près raisonnable
il peut rester effectivement sauf que là
il a un peu traqué quand même il y a un
peu de bruit autour donc il devrait
bouger oui bouger un peu il devrait donc
sa femme un peu plus rapidement il y a
beaucoup de chats de chiens
comme ça alors pour le coup Patrice moi
ce qui me vient à l'idée c'est que je
pense aux propriétaires alors ça peut
être un zoo ça peut être a priori serait
quand même personne a priori doit se
connaître
ça peut être un propriétaire donc c'est
uniquement particulier
moi ce que ça m'inspire c'est que voilà
récemment j'ai perdu mon chat et voilà
je suis resté 48 heures sans le voir je
vous garantis que ça fait ça fait drôle
donc je pense au propriétaire du tigre
qui doit être à peu près dans cet état
là mais plus sérieusement je pense aussi
voilà
mais plus sérieusement je pense
effectivement population autour ça
quand même
à nouveau donc ça veut dire qu'il est
sorti une fois de plus du lac là-bas en
Écosse est vraiment ça fait peur si
jamais la bête du Gévaudan revenait vous
imaginez déjà dans le bordel
un peu de tout et là ça va être terrible
alors on va passer quand même une sorte
d'exploit qui est d'un exploit européen
qui est qui est donc Rosetta et et
Versailles Saint-Quentin d'ailleurs
n'est pas étranger à cette exploit
puisque l'observatoire de Versailles
Saint-Quentin a participé à la
fabrication de Rosetta ils étaient tous
réunis d'ailleurs le jour où il a est
arrivé sur la comète on va regarder ce
sujet puis on en parle après
enfin filae se posait sur autre chose 20
ans qu'il l'attendait la mission est
approuvée par le comité de programmes
scientifique de l'ESA en 1993 mais
Rosetta n'est lancé que le 2 mars 2004
ici à Guyancourt c'est atterrissage et
marquant le premier sentiment c'est
l'émotion de voir une une entreprise qui
était singulière et qui était la
première de ce type là réussir une
récompense des gens qu'on travaillait
depuis très très longtemps et qu'il a
voit le fruit
se réaliser de l'ordre leurs efforts et
puis et puis donc voilà mais mis en
lumière le travail des gens sur cette
mission qui est qui est emblématique le
l'Atmos laboratoire atmosphère milieu
observation spatiale a participé à
l'élaboration de 7 des 20 instruments
présents à bord de Rosetta et Philae et
notamment concert un sondeur présent sur
l'orbiteur et sur le robot c'est un
travail international donc toutes les
données seront échangées entre les gens
qui sont impliqués l'enjeu pour nous
c'est de comprendre comment c'est
constitue une comète et après quels sont
les gaz qui s'échappent de cette comète
et qui la compose pour effectivement
comprendre qu'elle a pu être le rôle de
ces objets l'atterrissage n'a pas été
fait Philae a finalement rebondi pour
atterrir à un kilomètre de sa cible et
n'a pas réussi à déclencher ses harpons
il se trouverait sur une pente fortement
inclinée le manque d'ensoleillement
pourrait aussi écourter son
fonctionnement mais pour le moment le
robot fonctionne bien l'aventure doit se
conclure le 31 décembre 2015
voilà donc c'est un exploit un exploit
européen il faut le signaler c'est pas
c'est pas si courant et d'ailleurs c'est
très amusant parce que la NASA reçoit
plein de lettres de félicitations qui
reboot
vers des vers l'Europe qu'est-ce qui
vous qu'est-ce qui vous fascine dans
cette exploit technologique Jean-Charles
avant toute chose au-delà de la
technologie il y a le rêve absolu c'est
à dire que on va
se poser sur quelque chose qui a 4
milliards d'années ou 4 milliards et
demi d'années à 510 millions de
kilomètres c'est véritablement le rêve
humain c'est-à-dire que tout le monde a
dit que c'était aussi bien aussi
important que l'homme qui marchait sur
la lune je crois quand même pas mais
c'est absolument extraordinaire et quand
on a annoncé quelques années qui avait
plus de grands programmes européens
qu'on n'irait pas on irait pas sur Mars
avant 2050 qu'on retournerait jamais sur
la lune etc je trouve tout c'était un
petit peu éteint et là tout d'un coup
il y a une part de folie parce qu'on
voyait un truc sur une comète c'était le
ça permet quand même de savoir
les scientifiques vont bien évidemment
trouver des tonnes de choses on va on va
expliquer les mystères de l'univers de
la création de la terre ça c'est
extraordinaire et puis effectivement
c'est c'est génial parce que c'est un
truc européen et et pour une fois
l'Europe fait quelque chose de
absolument inattaquable on peut on peut
qu'être
fabuleux mais la part de rêve est
extrêmement importante je pense que même
pour les jeunes d'ailleurs c'est un dos
qui prouve la bonne gestion de l'Europe
parce que je me suis amusé à faire un
petit calcul on est à 500 millions de
kilomètres de la Terre 510 voilà sauf
que pour y arriver c'est pas une ligne
droite donc il a fallu faire des il a
fallu faire des tours et des détours je
crois qu'on doit être à 6 milliards de
kilomètres le programme doit coûter à
peu près 1,5 milliards d'euros au frais
kilométrique je trouve que c'est bien
géré
voilà mais à part ça c'est vrai
mais c'est vrai que pour une fois on
peut pas dire que l'argent de l'Europe
était mal dépensé
du kilomètre une aventure qui a coûté 20
centimes par an et par européen 20
centimes par an par personne en revanche
c'est vraiment ridicule en revanche
c'est vrai que c'est un vrai véritable
exploit technologique alors ça a
commencé il y a 20 ans elle était
envoyée il y a 10 ans
et finalement on découvre des choses
absolument extraordinaires mais c'est
surtout que ça ouvre un champ
d'interrogations supplémentaire
c'est-à-dire que ça fait 20 ans qu'on
travaille dessus donc on s'interroge
plus sur la manière d'y aller on l'a
prouvé en revanche à partir de
maintenant il y a tout un champ de
questionnement qui s'ouvre et c'est ça
qui me fascine aussi au-delà de la
technologie alors par rapport à la
technique par rapport à la technologie
c'est quand même le meilleur drone qu'on
ait pu utiliser parce que des drones on
en a vu ces derniers temps se balader on
sait pas trop qui les les manipulait là
c'est un véritable drone qu'il faut
quand même manipuler avec 20 minutes de
temps de réaction elle allait et en
retour à 500 millions de kilomètres
voilà donc je pense que il y a quand
même de l'espoir sur ce qu'on est
capable de faire ici aussi
et troisième point c'est l'infiniment
grand qui est très intéressant
d'observer ça ouvre le champ des
possibles mais en même temps ça me fait
penser que il y a aussi l'infiniment
petit sur lesquels on réfléchit aussi et
je pense qu'il y a une contribution
de cette de cette comment dire de cette
aventure spatiale je pense que les
technologies de l'infiniment grand
peuvent servir également l'infiniment
petit je pense à Ébola par exemple ça
m'a fait penser que
comment dire allez s'accrocher sur une
comète c'est un peu comme un virus qui
vient s'accrocher sur une cellule et qui
vient comme ça s’arrimer c'est même
processus que le processus viral
j'ai associé l'infiniment grand à
l'infiniment petit il transmet pas une
maladie là quand même mais j'en sais
rien j'en sais rien j'en sais rien en
l'occurrence on va peut-être chercher
des remèdes aussi sur la terre
c'est-à-dire que c'est pas simplement
très loin c'est aussi très présent aussi
ça nous concerne et tout ce qui est
développé en technologie pour
l'infiniment grand va servir à
l'infiniment petit donc à nous nous
humains sur Terre voilà c'était ça vous
fait rêver ça me fait rêver d'autant
plus que je sais qu'il est hiberné
pendant trois ans donc il y avait un
vrai doute on savait pas trop si ça
allait fonctionner ou pas et ce qui ce
qui est assez fantastique c'est
justement on va pouvoir comprendre
l'origine de la création de la terre
parce que c'est très bien expliqué c'est
une forme de d'avancer sur la
préhistoire du système solaire et on va
peut-être savoir ce qui nous attend
alors si on arrive à décoder ce qui
s'est passé avant ça nous permettra il y
avait beaucoup de candidats qui
voulaient aller sur Mars est-ce que vous
par exemple ça vous ferait rêver de vous
serez candidate pour aller sur Mars si
c'était possible
ce qui se passe au-delà des frontières
terrestres
je suis candidature pour la barre glacée
franchement je parle chocolaté mais là
franchement non c'est pas mon truc
j'aime beaucoup ce que vient de dire
Mustapha à travers l'espace et
effectivement on ne se rend pas compte
que le système solaire dans l'univers
n'est qu'une poussière et d'envoyer un
engin comme ça dans le système solaire à
500 millions de kilomètres c'est assez
extraordinaire moi je reviendrai aussi à
l'espace-temps est-ce que vous savez je
vais être très court si vous prenez un
calendrier du 1er janvier au 31 décembre
l'être vivant n'arrive sur terre que le
31 décembre vers 21h
l'être humain qui a 100 000 ans n'arrive
sur terre que vers 22h30 à l'échelle du
calendrier vous imaginez la terre à 5
milliards d'années on prévoit son
extinction dans 5 milliards d'années et
là en un espace temps très très court
des hommes dont la naissance vous a été
évoqué à la dernière émission par Robert
Cadalbert
grâce à une centrale nucléaire naturelle
extraordinaire qui a accéléré la
génétique là d'un seul coup on se
retrouve nous à pouvoir maîtriser une
petite partie mais quand même de 1
l'espace de l'espace-temps c'est juste
extraordinaire alors moi je ne suis
comme Jean-Charles je me dis quel rêve
incroyable mais combien de temps cela
va-t-il durer et surtout est-ce que ça
va nous donner la sagesse de protéger
notre planète mais c'est vrai que il y
avait longtemps peut-être que la science
nous avait pas fait autant rêver
absolument alors on va passer à des
choses qui sont un peu moins que nous
font peut-être un peu moins c'est
l'actualité politique d'abord il y a eu
hier un combat de titan qui s'est qui
sait le soldé par la victoire de
Jean-Christophe Lagarde sur Hervé Morin
à la présidence de l'UDI en fait on en
parle assez peu alors que le centre
c'est assez amusant parce que le centre
au fond c'est au gros ce qui gouverne la
France et c'est jamais représenté très
fortement politiquement
très amusante un combat de titan
personne n'a entendu parler on sait même
pas qui a voté
l'occasion beaucoup de triste dans les
votes pour un parti de notable ça la
foule 1500 voix d'avance pour l'un
c'est extrêmement curieux alors après ça
doit un petit peu faire les affaires de
Juppé parce que comme lui va se
positionner au centre d'avoir un centre
qui est aussi peu encore que la garde
dit qu'il veut se présenter au
présidentiel
c'est comme quoi les écolos ils disent
qu'ils veulent se présenter aussi voilà
c'est d'ailleurs triste de voir ça parce
que très honnêtement j'ai du respect
pour Monsieur Lagarde autant que pour
Monsieur Bourlon absolument monsieur
Borlo qui a créé un vrai mouvement et
qui avait une
personnalités c'est incontestable
maintenant ce qui est sûr en France
c'est que nous sommes dans un clivage
gauche droite que le centre n'existe pas
que la seule personnalité crédible au
sein de ses francs sur bureau et que
Monsieur Lagarde à côté de Monsieur
Beyrout bah c'est comme une puce à côté
d'un éléphant donc à un moment donné il
va falloir
je pense que c'est bon pour Véro qui
s'associera probablement avec Juppé pour
l'instant on n'est pas Madame Soleil ni
les un ni les autres on verra bien
c'est surtout que pour faire référence
au sujet d'avant on a parlé de force
gravitationnelle pour faire des
mouvements des mouvements en politique
il en faut aussi voilà donc c'est un
vrai combat de titan c'est vrai que ça a
pas fait beaucoup de bruit pour autant
mais c'est vrai que la droite a toujours
pensé qu'elle pouvait gouverner sans la
gauche ou probablement sans les pauvres
la gauche a probablement pensé qu'elle
pouvait gouverner sans la droite et
probablement sans les entrepreneurs
peut-être que le centre a oublié de
penser qu'elle pouvait gouverner sans la
droite et sans la gauche et là c'est
plutôt c'est plus égaux c'est plus
égocentrique que centré c'est plus des
batailles d'ego que des batailles au
centre voilà moi c'est ça que ça
m'inspire en même temps c'est vrai que
c'est pourtant la France est gouvernée
et arbitré
oui j'ai suivi alors c'est plus un
constat de fond c'est ça tient de la
palissade mais c'est vrai que on cherche
perpétuellement à cliver lorsque vous
regardez les débats à l'Assemblée
nationale on est vraiment dans la
rhétorique de position c'est pas très
constructeur au final on voit bien que
ça ne sert pas à grand-chose on avance
pas voudrais mieux chercher à rassembler
plus tôt car à se diviser en permanence
politique pour le faire c'est assez
intéressant cela dit parce que on voit
puisque on parle du centre il y a une
radicalisation du côté de du côté de
l'UMP Fillon qui vient de présenter son
programme qui parle dans le dans le
Figaro Magazine insiste beaucoup sur
l'immigration
Sarkozy de le fait déjà dans tous ces
meetings le maire le fait il y en a
qu'un qui dit au fond l'immigration des
pas un problème c'est Juppé donc le
candidat du centre ça pourrait on est
faite Juppé quoi c'est absolument ça
mais Juppé en ce moment tout tellement
auréolé de de sondage sympathique qui
qui pour une fois depuis le début de sa
carrière disque finalement il serait
sympathique qui ferait plus peur qui
serait même capable de sourire que c'est
il est au pays des bisounours il
redescend pas de son nuage Juppé c'est
extraire
des autres enfin ça prouve surtout que
dans le monde politique finalement c'est
pas ceux qui parlent le plus qui sont en
censés mais finalement ceux qui
parlerait le moins il a probablement
bien compris ça et il est à il se met à
l'abri de tout et finalement c'est ce
qui fait sa popularité d'ailleurs les
hommes politiques les gens
puisque justement sur l'immigration sur
la sur laquelle et Fillon et le maire et
Sarkozy prône une politique assez dure
lui il est plutôt pour une politique
ouverte donc c'est pas c'est pas son
risque vis-à-vis de l'électoral du MP
j'ai pas dit qu'il était muet j'ai dit
qu'il ne bavardait pas et qui ne
s'intéressait pas finalement assez
discussions dont on pourrait
éventuellement parler ici autour de
cette table ou au bas il est vraiment
sur des grands sujets sur des grands
thèmes et il se tient un fonctionnement
stratégique point et sur des dossiers
voilà des dossiers majeurs mais ils ne
concourt pas finalement à ce buzz où
tout le monde parle de tout c'est un peu
c'est un peu ça l'idée que il prend la
hauteur voilà pour l'instant il semble
un peu comme rester comme le candide le
candidat de droite idéal pour des gens
de gauche qui de toute façon de voteront
jamais à droite quoi c'est exactement
comme ça
on leur dit ah bon mais c'est génial
vous allez voter pour lui ah ben jamais
mon vote à droite
mais où où sont où sont les nouveaux
leaders qui doivent émerger la société
aujourd'hui est en train de rejeter tous
ces gens
oui par exemple
non non il faut que d'autres individus
femme ou homme émergent de de notre pays
et représente enfin les français tels
qu'ils sont peut-être d'ailleurs futur
leader
la semaine a été quand même marquée par
la faire Fillon juillet enfin on ne sait
pas si vous jouiez Fillon on ne sait pas
qui dit vrai qui dit faut Fillon fait un
procès pour avoir le le l'enregistrement
de de l'interview de juillet par les
journalistes du Monde mais ça va rien
apporter parce que on sait à peu près ce
qu'il a déjà dit du monde
c'est
monstrueux qu'on arrête tout ça mais
vraiment moi je dis que ces gens-là
aiment maintenant
à la pêche cultiver leur jardin et qui
laisse la place à des gens capables de
pouvoir mener ce pays et au lieu d'être
là à se gausser sur des choses
absolument sans intérêt pour l'avenir du
pays et encore une fois qui discrédit de
gravement le personnel politique dans
son ensemble
une image de la classe politique qui
ferait autre chose que des luttes
intestines au sein des clans la prise de
pouvoir c'est la politique j'ai
l'impression qu'on découvre l'eau chaude
avec lesquels j'ai l'occasion de
discuter longuement je vous assure que
les gens ils en ont assez de tout ça ils
veulent voir héberger des leaders
capables de gouverner ce pays mais que
les gens en est assez moi je peux le
comprendre simplement que les gens
sachent aussi que c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne tu es restaurateur je suis
sûr tu dois recevoir de temps en temps
des députés voir des gens qui sont pas
forcément du même bord et qui discutent
entre eux et de quoi ils discutent
souvent c'est c'est d'échiquier
politique local ou national
puis après il y en a un qui a déjà et il
semblerait qu'il y ait un quatrième
homme qui soit allé dans le bureau qui
serait tout en haut de la pyramide de
l'État et qui aurait dit ce que l'autre
n'a pas dit enfin bref c'est à vous
baigner de penser que c'est pas ça la
politique on a reçu notre ami Gad Elmer
la semaine dernière il s'est fait
débarquer avec un bilan sublime a-t-il
dit il s'est fait débarquer après une
période où il a vécu des choses
extraordinaires et pourtant ses amis
politiques lui ont demandé de laisser la
place à un autre vers la politique c'est
ça enfin
soyez pas surpris que parce que la
politique c'est ça les Français la
rejettent et à un moment donné il va
falloir non parce que ça c'est la
politique mais mais lorsqu'ils ont
finalement les éléments du pouvoir ils
doivent pour le coup gouverner et être
dans l'action et c'est des actions dont
on doit parler après la manière dont ils
veulent accéder au pouvoir on sait que
c'est comme ça que ça se passe mais il y
a une différence entre accéder au
pouvoir avoir le pouvoir et avoir
l'action du pouvoir et moi je parle de
l'action c'est ça qui m'intéresse c'est
l'action mais la manière dont on arrive
au pouvoir c'est ça les gars
avec son ancien ministre
vous pouvez retrouver un ancien
collaborateurs
ici en effet Fillon a demandé
d'accélérer le procédure contre ça mais
maintenant le mal est fait parce qu'il y
aura jamais c'est impossible d'avoir la
preuve de quoi que ce soit
alors on voit déjà ça porte tort à
Fillon puisque dans les sondages il est
en train de baisser terriblement et
celui auquel ça peut vraiment porter
préjudice c'est juillet parce qu'il dit
qu'il n'a pas dit si c'est sur les
bandes là ça va être dramatique pour lui
et au final ce qui est terrible c'est
comme dans les faire Clearstream avant
vous vous rappelez sûrement de cette
affaire incroyable le mec qu'on vise qui
s'appelle Nicolas Sarkozy parce que
clairement c'est lui qui est visé bon
il a une capacité lui de jouer le
billard à trois bandes de façon
absolument extraordinaire dans l'affaire
sclessim qui était normalement la mort
assurée de Nicolas Sarkozy et il est
tenu président de la République dans
cette affaire où il est visé parce que
vous savez que derrière il y a quoi il y
a les amandes dans l'UMP il y a le
financement de la campagne etc et on
s'aperçoit finalement celui qui va
porter le chapeau à mon avis c'est
Hollande
plus j'étais assez je n'ai pas dit que
je voulais
que finalement on a l'impression de
découvrir le monde politique en réalité
c'est celui-ci et que ça soit sur le
plan local que sur le plan national il y
a des luttes de pouvoir c'est le chemin
qui mène au pouvoir
que nous tous
les jeunes de voir qui a pas d'intégrité
qui a pas d'honnêteté alors on sait bien
que la politique n'est pas le vivier de
ses valeurs là mais
on pourrait dire le contraire on
pourrait dire qu'après tout Fillon il
voudrait que la vérité soit établie sur
les conditions et que c'était plutôt
honnête de savoir
mais de la passer par ce genre de moyen
chercher à interférer sur le pouvoir
judiciaire c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
la bonne façon de faire
après ce genre de bassesse sont quand
même relativement propre à l'UMP il y en
a une nécessairement avec le PS mais je
dois dire que le l'UMP Excel en la
matière est-ce que ce qu'il faut pas le
plus boit c'est ce qui m'a presque le
plus dans cette affaire c'est que un
ancien Premier ministre et un secrétaire
général de l'Elysée puisse avouer comme
ça qu'on peut agir sur la justice que je
croyais moi indépendantes
jusque là c'est parce que au fond
on dit qu'il s'est dit est vrai c'est
que le premier ministre demande
l'exponhubisme demande d'agir sur la
justice demande que le pouvoir exécutif
agit sur pouvoir judiciaire ce qui est
quand même non je pense que croire qu'il
y a une réelle indépendance ça relève de
l'utopie je pense qu'il y a
nécessairement des interférences et des
moyens de pression qui ont toujours été
mis en place je pense qu'il y a certains
moments c'est mieux cacher qu'à d'autres
et en l'occurrence ça a fuité et c'est
ce qui qui va leur nuire mais le
discrédit vous pensez qu'il y a un
cabinet noir à l'Élysée c'est ça si j'ai
bien compris cabinet noir
aussi s'éprouvait qu'est-ce qu'il doit
faire ils doivent démissionner ils
doivent
flagrantes comme Monsieur Cahuzac est
parti comme monsieur thévenou est parti
bien sûr non il est même pas partir
il y a quand même une chose c'est
redondant avec le sujet précédent ils
ont ils ont été élu d'une part d'abord
on sait pas encore si c'est pas vrai
bon et puis voilà après c'est pas non
plus une affaire d'état enfin je veux
dire que que trois types sur 577 et
caché de l'argent ou pas oui c'est enfin
c'est pas c'est pas capital il y a
beaucoup plus grave et beaucoup plus
grave individuellement c'est quand même
oui oui oui
il était de gauche où il était parti
socialiste c'était scandaleux
différents il était ministre du Budget
est député c'est pas pareil
je suis bien sûr en revanche si je suis
que simple député je peux me permettre
de frauder un peu
le ministre il est avéré c'était un
truand ça c'est c'est sûr et certain là
il y a des suspicions comme par hasard
qui arrive en disant tiens ces trois-là
ils sont tous les trois en train de dire
on a déclaré on a déclaré cet argent et
je vais le prouver et c'est ton ancien
ami puisqu'il était dans le foot ton ami
brochant hein bon il y a un million
d'euros que des amis dans le foot
je l'ai déclaré il y a rien de
il y a rien de caché on va voir si c'est
vrai ou pas mais voilà en attendant on
peut aussi avoir une certaine
présomption d'innocence parce qu'on sort
comme ça
si jamais c'était avéré voilà
on va que la justice qui est
indépendante
et sortent les affaires finalement mais
là où j'avais cru comprendre que
finalement il y aurait une immunité
graduelle en fonction du poste qu'on en
aurait là je te rejoins pas il y a quand
même il y a pas d'immunités quand on est
ministre on se doit d'être encore plus
exemplaires sur son ministre du Budget
je pense que la réaction de Jean-Charles
elle est assez symptomatique du fait
qu'il y a une forme de normalisation
justement dans la société exactement de
la fraude parmi les politiques on l'a
condamne moins on se met à la tolérer il
y a une forme de résignation qui conduit
non mais c'est parce que la France est
un pays de fraudeur tout le monde tout
le monde frône tout le monde essaye de
France
un peu de
je pense que des politiques devraient
beaucoup plus s'intéresser mais les
médias aussi il y a un sujet mon cher
Patrice que tu as sauvé qui me paraît
extrêmement important c'est d'économie
de partage par exemple là les politiques
normalement devraient pouvoir intervenir
parce qu'on est en train de par
terre toute une économie donc à un
moment donné là les politiques devraient
on le voit avec par exemple le
covoiturage c'est-à-dire on partage la
même voiture mais ça existe aussi on
peut trouver des logements pour les
routards par exemple des logements
gratuits on peut manger gratuitement
on partage la musique alors là ça c'est
assez courant maintenant c'est sur
Internet c'est c'est vrai que c'est une
économie qui n'est d'Internet et qui
fait que qui qui est une économie un peu
parallèle l'économie nationale vous vous
la craignez cette et c'est une grande
tour nous sur le plan de notre secteur
d'activité on craint ça comme la peste
parce qu'aujourd'hui n'importe qui peut
se transformer en hôtelier j'ai deux
chambres chez les loups n'importe qui
votre voisin peut se faire restaurateur
j'ai une grande table j'accueille si
personne il paye chacun leur écho et
vas-y et ce sont des concurrents directs
dans notre secteur d'activité sauf que
les hôteliers professionnels ou les
restaurateurs professionnels sont soumis
évidemment à des règles
des taxes à des charges sur les salaires
etc et évidemment que nous sommes là
dans une situation extrêmement
dangereuse alors de deux choses l'une ou
bien on autorise cela et auquel cas il
faut évidemment complètement mettre les
restaurateurs au même niveau que
l'indépendant qui va louer sa chambre
dans la maison ou bien l'inverse c'est
évidemment plutôt l'inverse qui va se
passer bien évidemment mais là le
politique doit avoir une vraie vision de
la situation parce que nous sur le plan
de notre secteur d'activité on est en
train de tuer un pan entier de
l'économie et c'est extrêmement grave et
dangereux pour toute la suite qu'on va
donner à nos métiers restaurateurs cafés
hôteliers etc et donc là le politique
bizarrement ne réagit pas et pendant ce
temps-là le système de marchand par
Internet moi je vois pour prendre un
exemple très simple d'un site internet
de commentaires dont je ne citerai pas
le nom américain qui fait 3 milliards
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires en 5 ans
dont un milliard d'euros de profits sans
avoir versé 1 centime de taxes à la
France je dis au secours et que fait le
politique rien dans les commentaires
sont assez bidons paraît-il bon voilà
mais je vais pas rentrer dans le détail
simplement une un autre système de
réservation par Internet le plus grand
du secteur est devenu aujourd'hui la
plus grosse
usine à cash du monde et à doubler en
cash ce que faisait Apple dont un moment
donné il faut quand même que le
politique s'intéresse au sujet parce que
sinon on va tous crever
tout ça c'est la fin de bien entendu
exactement
solidaire voilà on part solidarité on
arrivait à affronter la crise qui nous
touche plus ou moins tous mais quand
même pourquoi avoir une voiture si on
peut en avoir voilà et je trouvais que
c'était rentré dans une dynamique
mais pour le coup l'enfer est pavé de
bonnes intentions et là en l'occurrence
les intentions sont louables
c'est-à-dire que l'idée c'est on est en
période de crise en partant on ne peut
pas tout acheter donc on peut
éventuellement partager mais c'est vrai
que si on partageait tout derrière ça il
faudrait soit tout déréglementer
d'ailleurs c'est le sujet vous allez
parler de sexe
non mais en revanche ça me fait penser
également à l'histoire de la
déréglementation des professions qui
sont cités les professions libérales en
l'occurrence donc la pharmacie les
notaires etc donc on est dans une
société où on cherche finalement des
solutions on pense que celle-ci on
serait une et là pour le coup on
pourrait déréglementer en clair tout le
monde pourrait être
pharmacien tout le monde pourrait être
notaire de la même façon qu'on pourrait
être tous restaurateurs ou ateliers
alors c'est vrai que l'intention
l'intention est louable mais c'est vrai
que probablement qu'on irait vers un
enfer programmé et surtout quand on
disait que les politiques ne sont
attaquaient pas aux problèmes du partage
si s'attaquent au partage sauf qu'ils
partagent entre eux d'après ce que j'ai
compris ce matin mais mais bien sûr mais
c'était on peut faire quelques on peut
on a le droit d'être un peu ici quand
même de temps en temps sur des sujets
aussi
c'est bien évidemment
comme je viens de le dire mais c'était
juste pour le pour le bouton mais c'est
vrai que l'enfer est pavé de bonnes
intentions c'est-à-dire que globalement
on vit quand même dans une société
découvre une autre une façon de voir le
problème c'est encore une fois on attend
des politiques cette vision
de la gratuité derrière ça m'inquiète
beaucoup parce qu'au-delà des règles bon
c'est pas très grave parce que j'espère
que tu fais la différence quand même et
que c'est très bon chez toi et que c'est
meilleur c'est moi si j'ouvre un
restaurant en 3 minutes donc tu vas
survivre grâce à la qualité des plats et
moi grâce à la qualité de mes livres
voilà si tu on fait du bon boulot on
s'en sort monsieur mais sinon c'est
comme une économie qui tourne vers la
décroissance totale c'est-à-dire que
dire aux gens n'achetaient plus de
voiture n'achetez plus de livres n'allez
plus au cinéma partager les choses
c'est-à-dire que il y aura plus de
boulot pour personne c'est-à-dire que là
c'est un changement de société
absolument total c'est à dire que il y a
plus rien et et les journaux qui passent
leur temps à dire on a une bonne idée
pour vous faire économiser de l'argent
alors au lieu d'acheter un truc plein
pot mettez-vous à 4 pour acheter une
demi-baguette et puis comme ça il y aura
pas du tout de gâchis etc mais c'est
lamentable parce que c'est je veux dire
c'est c'est là où tous les jours les
commerces et tout le monde va crever si
si sauf les pharmaciens parce que tout
le monde se rendait pas exactement mais
c'est mais on va voir les médicaments
bien sûr les hypermarchés je rebondis
parce que tout ça est lié à l'absence
totale de vision de nos leaders
politiques regardez ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui de dans la grande
distribution vous voyez fleurir des
drive partout bon la grande distribution
on le sait tous est en train de se tirer
des balles dans le pied tous les matins
pourquoi parce que le fait de mettre des
drive il y en a sur la nationale 10 là
en ce moment qui se mettent dedans
partout c'est quoi c'est de pouvoir
étendre la surface de commerce sans
passer par la CDC d'accord c'est tout
bête quand faut-il que les Français le
sachent on met des drive partout parce
que ça permet au fait d'augmenter les
surfaces de vente des magasins sans
passer par les CDC mais c'est
extrêmement dangereux parce que c'est la
commission départementale qui autorise
ou pas
l'agrandissement ou la création de
mètres carrés de commerce c'est
extrêmement important or vous voyez bien
que là nous sommes aussi entrer dans un
système qui va être catastrophique
pourquoi parce que d'abord
il se trouve que le drive répond à une
demande des jeunes couples par exemple
pas tant et faire les courses en pierre
et Cali mais selon on va dans les drive
allô machin on va prendre la voiture
c'est fini et qu'est-ce qui se passe
évidemment
le nombre de passage dans les grands
hypermarchés diminue et par dessus le
marché ça fait diminuer aussi le passage
dans les galeries commerciales dans ses
propriétaires font payer des loyers for
chers à la limite du raquette et donc
automatiquement qu'est-ce qui passe
aujourd'hui il se passe que nous avons
une dégringolade de fréquentation dans
les centres commerciaux dans les
hypermarchés qui va au détriment des
locataires qui sont là et qui sont
aujourd'hui étranglés parce que on a mis
des drives dans tous les sens et bien là
aussi le politique n'a rien fait alors
que il suffisait simplement qu'ils
disent attention la construction des
dragées est également soumis à la CDEC à
la commission départementale et dans ce
cas nous aurions freiné un système qui
va conduire et les hypers et les centres
commerciaux à la catastrophe dans un
calendrier qui va prendre entre 5 et 10
ans c'est extrêmement grave non je
réglemente rien je dis simplement que
les hommes politiques et les femmes
politiques doivent prendre conscience
les des choses qui sont en train de se
passer et je demande pas ce qu'ils y
faire je demande à ce qu'ils aient une
vision parce que
ce qu'on attend des gens de la politique
c'est que il nous conduisent vers le
succès non pas vers l'échec c'est tout
un bémol Jean-Luc c'est que la nature
aura du vide ce que tu es en train de
dire est vrai c'est-à-dire que
finalement
je finis je finis je finis mon
raisonnement
la visibilité des produits de ces mêmes
supermarchés va diminuer c'est-à-dire
que finalement toutes ces têtes de
gondole qu'on a mises pour attirer le
chaland toutes ces promo internes pour
attirer le Chalon toute cette animation
est supermarché pour attirer le Chalon
bah ça n'aura plus d'utilité donc du
coup la consommation va baisser
également de ses propres
supermarché donc les gens achèteront
probablement aussi ailleurs et ce qui
est terrible c'est que les patrons
savent très bien qu'ils sont en train de
tirer des balles probablement c'est en
fait dans un système pour une raison
c'est
que la société représentée par le
pouvoir politique c'est son boulot n'a
rien vu venir pas plus d'ailleurs que
nous avons vu venir les sites de
réservation d'hôtels et de restaurants
par internet et on se tire des balles
dans le quai tout le temps et qu'est-ce
que ça amène ça amène évidemment une
diminution des marges partout on veut du
moins cher du moins cher très bien mais
à partir du moment où les entreprises
travaillent à perte elle meurt et bien
on est en train de degrés de voir
aujourd'hui toute une grande partie de
l'économie en train de mourir et ça
c'est grave ici alors on va parler de
mort justement mais qui va nous ramener
plutôt vers le passé là on était vers un
avenir qui n'est pas très enchanteur on
va regarder un passé qui n'était pas
très gai non plus c'était celui de la
guerre de 14 en fait le centenaire de la
guerre de 14 avec des commémorations il
y a une commémoration par exemple à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux on regarde et
puis on en parle après
à Montigny-le-Bretonneux la
commémoration de l'Armistice rassemble
aujourd'hui peu importe la génération
une seule chose compte le souvenir
Albert
savoureux Jean-Marie
cette année 250 élèves participaient à
la cérémonie pour rendre hommage des
lectures de textes Sarah el a lu la
lettre écrite par un enfant pour son
père sur le
fronts
et malgré leur jeune âge le devoir de
mémoire semble bien assimilé c'est très
important
il y en a qui ont fait la guerre ils se
sont pas ils se sont battus pour
Montigny la France et on a besoin de
leur rendre hommage pour tout ce qu'ils
ont fait la guerre 14-18
c'est un symbole c'est
c'est important pour nous mourir pour la
France c'est quelque chose et c'est pas
c'est pas comme jouer ou se rappeler de
ses morts mais aussi et surtout prévenir
les générations futures ce qui s'est
passé auparavant nous permet de mieux
affronter l'avenir avec peut-être en
modifiant certaines erreurs la seule
chose que j'avais retenue lorsque
j'étais petit c'est que le vin était
gelé durant la guerre et qui découpait
le vin à la hache et quand on est enfant
ça ça surprend après les dépôts de gerbe
devant le monument aux morts les enfants
entonnent la Marseillaise
ému les représentants des villes
jumelles de Grande-Bretagne et
d'Allemagne ont assisté à la cérémonie
c'était très très impressionnant parce
que nous on connaît pas ça on fait pas
on ne fait pas de tel cérémonie chez
nous les cérémonies pour les
pour les mots qui sont tombés dans les
guerres ça se déroule presque dans la
clandestinité c'est impressionnant pour
louer très très émouvant surtout quand
on a vu les petits là qui chantaient la
Marseillaise enfin direction l'ancienne
mairie pour se recueillir une dernière
fois devant la plaque des instituteurs
ici on chantera une fois encore l'hymne
national cette fois à la demande des
enfants
Sephora c'est commémoration ça vous
touche ça vous dit quelque chose
ça me touche de temps que j'ai été
militaire trois ans donc je suis pas
forcément si si représentative d'une
jeunesse normale on va dire donc oui
nécessairement j'en ai fait des
cérémonies sur la place
j'ai été hôtesse de l'air dans un
escadron un peu spécial qui était
dévolu au convoi gouvernementaux donc
oui oui donc c'est pour ça que oui ça me
touche vraiment je pense être patriote
comme comme un jeune et c'est vrai que
j'y porte une attention particulière
alors c'est vrai que c'est c'est
émouvant d'ailleurs parce que j'y étais
j'y étais pendant 14
je connais maintenant
pas en 14 mais par contre non j'étais
attrape pour la commémoration du du
centenaire du début de cette de la
guerre 1914 donc j'y étais c'est vrai
que c'était un moment très très émouvant
d'ailleurs on a parlé à l'occasion
célébrée le centenaire de la mort
également de Jaurès
de contre commémoration puisque c'est la
statue de Jean Jaurès qui était contre
la guerre de 14 qui a été qui a été
inauguréat à trappe enfin qui était
qu'on a vu à trace donc
la guerre de 14
c'est quand même
passé en France c'est quand même pas
l'oublier c'est pas passé
principalement quand même en France la
guerre de 14 tout le monde était et donc
on peut de temps en temps faire un
événement et commémorer un événement
j'allais dire vous allez vous fout de
moi mais presque entre nous enfin je
veux dire voilà
c'est ça
la raison même d'être de l'Europe
il y a un seul engagement à avoir pour
l'Europe non mais cela dit que l'Europe
se manifeste en 1910 en 2018 parce que
là c'est quand même très curieux de
commémorer l'entrée en guerre alors
d'abord on se trompant de date parce que
l'entrée en guerre c'est au mois d'août
et là on commémore la fin de la guerre
11 novembre mais le 11 novembre 4 ans
plus tard donc un espèce de mélange pour
les enfants qui doit être total
qu'est-ce qu'on commémore ne veut pas
dire valider commémorer c'est dire
comment ça va commémoriste
pour personne le 11 novembre c'était
avant le 12 et après le 13 enfin oui
mais enfin dans ce cas-là dans ce cas-là
la Révolution
et puis on commémorale 11 novembre 2018
et là avec l'Europe sera du sens qu'on
pourrait discuter sur les dates mais ce
qui est important c'est de commémorer
une date un anniversaire pour se
souvenir de comment ça s'est passé
comment ça s'est produit et d'ailleurs
le fait que ça soit un concomitant
d'ailleurs le en même temps il est mort
à ce moment-là c'était difficile de
commémorer deux choses différentes je
parle de Jaurès c'est une manière de se
souvenir aussi comment ça a commencé ce
souvenir commence à terminer et se dire
que c'est fini en 18 c'est important
c'est bien aussi de savoir comment
une petite commémoration
cette année 2014 on a été quand même
très largement par les commémorations
l'une 500 l'autre à un moment donné faut
se dire bon très bien le passé c'est
important
respecter les femmes et les hommes qui
sont morts sur les champs de bataille
pour défendre les valeurs de leur patrie
j'ai bien compris que vous étiez
patriote et c'est bien je félicite de ça
parce que tous les jeunes ne le disent
pas aussi franchement que vous bon c'est
bien mais bon une fois par an ça va quoi
une stratégie de communication
mais quand même je voudrais revenir à
Jean Jaurès et par rapport à ce que nous
disons tout à l'heure à propos de la
vision
ça prend quelques secondes mais je vais
vous lire ce que Jaurès écrivait dans la
Dépêche juste de juste deux secondes
dirige
celui qui risque ce que les dirigés ne
veulent pas risquer avec leur épargne
écoutez bien cette phrase il y en a
d'autres derrière je vais vous les lire
mais je reste je reste avec quand même
une vision assez extraordinaire la
société en 1900 en 1890 il est assassiné
en 1914 et relisez bien ce qu'a écrit je
reste d'abord c'est ses œuvres et
ensuite ces articles cette socialiste et
bien il avait une vision totalement trop
entreprise dirait aujourd'hui monsieur
Valls bah il l'avait déjà lui en 1890 et
malheureusement il n'a pas suffisamment
été écouté
assez écouté pour être assassiné
alors très vite je vais vous dire trois
mots et on va on va aller très vite sur
chacun de ces sujets les JO alors
Hollande dit voilà ça serait bien de
réaliser les JO en 2024 la mère de Paris
a l'air un peu plus réticente est-ce que
ça serait c'est par exemple grâce au JO
que le vélodrome de Saint-Quentin existe
bonne chose ou une mauvaise chose il
faut y aller ou
il faut faire des économies c'est
dangereux c'est toujours une c'est
toujours une bonne chose d'avoir ce type
d'événement à condition que ça soit pas
un fiasco-financier non plus et qu'on
n'est pas la démesure le vélo Drôme
c'était prévu à 70 millions d'euros
probablement qu'on a atteint les plus de
100 millions aujourd'hui je sais pas ce
que ça rapporte et donc en termes de
rentabilité même si on a bien compris la
dernière fois que une dette devait être
associée à un actif sauf que si l'actif
est mort il n'est pas rentable par
définition c'est plus une dette pour le
coup c'était c'est une perte mais ça
reste ça reste un événement important
Mustapha on est vraiment l'exemple là
que à partir du moment où on parle de
grands événements sportifs on parle que
de fric oui ça suffit quoi bon c'est
autre chose
olympiques et quand dégringole un peu
les exigences financières ça suffit je
vous rappelle quand même que les grands
événements
vous le savez dans l'Antiquité dans la
culture grecque d'ailleurs était fait
d'abord pour que les peuples puissent
s'affronter pacifiquement sur les et ça
occasionnait une trêve absolue plus
personne ne se battait pendant les Jeux
Olympiques
aujourd'hui
dans l'arène mais aujourd'hui moi je
préfère que les peuples
avec des tanks et donc à un moment donné
je pense qu'il faut arrêter de ne parler
que d'argent lorsqu'on parle
d'événements sportifs il faut parler de
sport et d'affrontements
je trouve que oui des gros événements
les politiques des travaux des grands
travaux ça peut avoir du sens
économiquement sûrement donc ça c'est le
côté économique sinon le côté un peu
troublant c'est que ça a encore une fois
une une parole du président qui a
discrédité la fonction c'est-à-dire que
il se il est traité comme un mois que
rien par Anne Hidalgo qui peut amener
rien ni personne ne me fera changer la
vie elle parle du président de la
République mais jamais personne n'aurait
osé faire la même chose avec un
président précédent ou n'importe lequel
les autres présidents présidents et là
on se moque d'un Land et tout le monde
ça fait rire tout le monde ne sait pas
le sport pour le sport c'est vrai
faudrait revenir malheureusement c'est
pas la tendance actuelle il faut quand
même savoir qu'à Athènes et à Londres
sur du 10 milliards de dépenses
publiques pour des recettes élevées à 2
milliards donc je pense que oui les JO
ce serait bien mais pas pour tout de
suite alors un nom aussi qui a beaucoup
fait l'actualité qui est à Versailles
aujourd'hui c'est Nabilla
victime coupable qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez victime victime de sa célébrité
c'est l'évidence une petite musique
enfin en tout cas une musique
un peu simplette Nabila elle est pas non
plus alors jeter comme ça en pâture la
presse people dans un univers qui est
très
différente etc elle était sûrement
fragile avant c'est sûrement pour ça
qu'on l'a choisi comme vedette de
téléréalité parce qu'elle avait un peu
quelques failles et psychologiques qui
sont sûrement qui sont qui du coup sont
amusantes dans une émission non mais
c'est amusant dans une émission
quelqu'un qui va péter un câble on le
sait si les gens étaient parfaitement
équilibré
il serait pas candidat dans des
émissions télé-réalité donc c'est elle
est victime de de de vous a fait rêver
ou pas
justement je trouve ça dommage qu'il y a
un tel engouement en fait autour de
Nabilla parce que ce qu'elle véhicule
comme image de la femme comme image de
la jeunesse c'est un peu dommage il y a
des gens qui s'identifient et qui
devraient passer par un joli modèle
après ce qui est quand même assez
symptomatique c'est que tout le monde la
connaît quelque part parce que justement
on la voit à la télé réalité et tout
donc il y a une forme de familiarisation
et aujourd'hui on la prend en sympathie
et on la prend en pitié presque on dira
la pauvre elle est écrouée elle a
poignardé son copain c'est vraiment la
patience bon elle a quand même si tenté
qu'elle les fait elle a quand même
planté donc
il y a deux choses qu'on peut dire
c'est que elle a utilisé un a priori un
petit couteau elle aurait éventuellement
planté ce couteau sauf que c'est au
juste de trancher
enfin c'est un fait divers banal avec
des gens sans intérêt et on en fait des
grands sujets d'information au même
niveau que la façon dont l'Europe ou
quand vous savez que les émissions de
télévision
c'est vrai que c'est voilà c'est
croustillant et les gens aiment aussi
pour ça que la presse people fonctionne
bien c'est pour ça qu'on voit beaucoup
de de reportages sur ce type de
personnage et en même temps Nabilla elle
est mis elle est dans la lumière bon
aujourd'hui on l'a mis à l'ombre c'est
vrai que c'est un peu tous ces contrats
merci infiniment à tous les quatre de ce
tour de tour de rideau de l'actualité on
se retrouve dans 15 jours pour un
prochain pass merci beaucoup Sephora
merci à vous
merci à très vite donc pour un prochain
PAF